what's up fortnite fam  zeke here as the chapter 2 season 6  primal season rages on  we're taking a look at this week's  all-new item the recycler  perfect for 10 situations when you're  low on ammo  this two-handed heavy takes advantage of  junk scattered across the island  you can load it up with just about  anything for ammo  from trees to rocks to that dumpster  simply aim and it'll start picking up  resources to reuse for a hefty junk bomb  yes it's that easy and when you're ready  to fire  the recycler's effective and explosive  attack will deal damage to enemies and  help you tear down  their builds it's all about the rubble  baby  already in the game we can't wait to see  how you use  and reuse the recycler fire back your  best videos  and screenshots using fortnite recycler  that's it for this update we'll see you  guys on the battle bus